the Joe Rogan experience um unless you
day do you spend thinking about this
well I am an eternal researcher and I'm
always looking for stories I love the
MUFON stuff that's coming out you know
my family was into paranormal research
that's why I wrote the Ghostbusters uh
my dad was a researcher and my and his
father that's why you wrote Ghostbuster
yeah because because we have an old farm
in Canada and my grandfather was a
dentist in Kingston Ontario in the in
the 20s and a man walked up to him he
had been researching psychic research
and the other world and mediumship for
many years and a guy walked up to him
and said mister are dr. Aykroyd I
believe that I have a gift and his name
was Walter Ashurst he was a locomotive
mechanic at the local engine works and
he was our family medium for for at
least 10 or 15 years and we would have
they would have seances and then 20s and
30s and Sunday afternoon the big dodges
and Cadillacs would pull up in the women
the matrons would get out and my
great-grandfather would have a 90-minute
session with the medium and they would
channel entities from the other side
have you heard of the Fox sisters and
the whole Lilydale thing the whole
mediumship of the concept that you know
we are the life billet lives beyond what
we have here do you know who John
Edwards
as the the psychic on television yeah
isn't [ __ ] no busted noise well you
know what happy busted with an earpiece
well hey John Edwards the psychic got
busted he was he had some very well
maybe you know sometimes what happens is
they they you know they lose their
powers in they and they are unable to or
they're full of [ __ ] the entire time
that just gets living John Edwards
though I I watched a show I kind of
believed him but I'm sure if he was the
one that got busted and one of those one
of those psychics got busted yeah so I'd
like to see you across from Penn
Jillette yeah of course no he's like to
him well he's an expert debunk horrible
yeah yeah super skeptical I would I'd
love to have Penn Jillette tell me what
he thinks of the Fox sisters why why
they went around the world with a spirit
that performed with them right what
happened well it wrapped a spirit
wrapped yeah okay our AP not-not-not
reading yeah yeah oh I thought wow like
muse and reverberant rapping
now I'd love to I'd love to you know so
it's a spirograph mediumship that's
that's a very very telling I by Insane
Clown Posse are yeah Slipknot there we
but I I believe that we the
consciousness can survive after death
there's a school called Arthur Findlay
college in England and you can go there
and train to be a medium why you'd want
to I don't I don't know it's very
exhausting you imagine shutting down
your whole system going into and trance
reaching the other side having that
entity come through the other side use
your body yours your fluids use
everything and then abandon you after
and then just go you it's exhausting
exhausting but my family research
mediumship and I wrote Ghostbusters
based upon you know it's just our family
interest from the Fox the Fox sisters
your sisters you should get them up
there's a picture of them foxes in 1848
they were lying in bed in their new
house near Hyde's Ville New York and all
of a sudden this kind of wrapping
started terrifying them they thought it
was confined just to that house in
Hinesville but they managed to take it
around they in one of they went to
Rochester it happened in houses when
they went to a theater it happened in
front of three four hundred people and
they've actually they toured the world
with this act they called it the peddler
and he was someone who was killed and
murdered and buried in the house in the
basement John Edwards a hoser here
Popoff there they are
John Edwards I looked him up it didn't
come up necessarily he was they were all
they were all and they went around the
world tipping tables and and and yeah
that's a drawing real people they never
existed no they did they did they were
they were and they were very well
scrutinized Maggie in the end of her
life said no we were we were produced we
were producing these reverberant Wow
they have a head what is that is that
them know what place that that's doubt
of my realm there's something about
mean-faced ladies from like the 1800s
scare the [ __ ] out yeah there's there's
the cottage there's such a yeah hard
time to be alive that's the cottage that
had occurred in and you know they said
it was the ghost of the peddler that lit
that was murdered in the basement and
they look down they did find some bones
but every time they tried to build the
ground water a dig for the bones the
ground water kept
anyway Maggie at the end of her life
said no no we were faking it I was
creating the wraps Maggie said she was
Maggie said she was faking it but she
said I was creating the wraps these
reverberate in concert halls right with
my knees and my knuckles you know now I
can crack my knuckles maybe in my knees
but you can't make them they were
slapstick there were wrappings and then
yeah and then she recanted it and said
the skeptics you know made me do it I
was talked into but there was so much
pressure on me and in the end of her
life she then recanted her recant her
retraction of it but I'm very convincing
that was the origin of spirituality
people were looking for a new religion
you had Mormonism that had come in in
the 20s you had all kinds of
Protestantism that area of New York was
called the burned-over district because
the preachers had all been through there
people who were believing in all kinds
of different religion they were looking
for something new and spiritual
spirituality and spiritualism gave them
that but you know I've had I've had
people contact me that have passed in
dreams I've never seen a ghost I've
never you know experienced that but I I
do believe that consciousness survives
after death I I do believe that it's an
interesting idea there's no evidence
that it doesn't you know I think that
reincarnation is also a fascinating
concept that's repeated in many
different cultures mm-hm and I wonder
why you know there's a great Tyler
Childers song called born again and it's
it's about things living and dying and
being reincarnated in in different times
I and I think that's very attractive to
people the idea that our physical body
is one thing but the spiritual body is
something entirely different well I
think that you know atheists and
attractive it is attractive atheists are
never gonna believe that they're not
going to accept that it's hopeful it
gives us a little hope and after all you
know the Koreans they who was that they
were a Russian research research group
they're famous for the experiment where
they are the Kirlian photography ki-rin
and you want a little citrus they they
they they photographed a woman she sat
there and she was able to blow smoke
into a fishbowl and shape the smoke in
the fishbowl so here are some Kirlian
images they have faith they photographed
auras and they did photograph they did
you know 21 grams is supposed to be the
rate of the weight of the soul and they
they photographed a guy dying and they
claimed to have photographed his aura
leaving his body yeah yeah all these
claims is their photograph of this
photograph I've heard I don't know of
atomic weight of the soil 21 grams and
Kirlian photo of dying men I don't know
but there you saw the auras the
photographs there why would the soul
have weight if it doesn't have a
physical embodiment yeah well energy
energy mass energy what electricity
doesn't know anyway does it what's going
well I don't know I think that it acts
as a certain force there's there it's
certainly a force so there's guys that's
that's an interesting question but mass
is what right reacts to scales gravity
yep right I mean well electrons you know
if there's a mass there there's an
atomic mass atomic weight any one gram
seems like a lot it does it does seem
like a lot yeah
fat ass soul but but the Killians were
yeah